what do you do from here as a front
office
yeah christian i don't know that i want
to address the hypotheticals of what may
happen in the future here you know i
think this this is pretty raw pretty
fresh i think we've got to let the dust
settle um the hope is that we we have
kyrie back you know we'll welcome him
back in open arms under a different set
of circumstances and so we need to wait
and see how that transpires but in the
meantime you know we need to focus on
the 16 players that um that are going to
be on this roster moving forward you
know with us including our two ways so
the focus needs to be with them and our
goals have not changed you know the
goals you know ultimately still
uh ought to be the last team standing
and that's we're going to be and without
a doubt
losing a player of of kyrie's caliber
hurts from a talent perspective no
question i'm not going to deny that but
the end of the day we our focus our
coaches focus the organization's focus
needs to be on those players they're
going to be involved here and
participating uh fully